howdy I am Walter Bernays yak and this
is top 5 here we countdown the best and
worst performances of our most beloved
actors today we take a look at the best
of Aflac you got it Ben Affleck Ben
Affleck has been around a long time
longer than one might think and despite
some ups and downs in his career he's
actually pretty consistently been a
really good actor over the past several
years he's also established himself as a
quality director he's put out some great
performances to couple with his new job
behind the camera his newest the
accountant hits theaters this weekend so
to mark the occasion let's count down
his top 5 best performances number 5
Chuckie Sullivan in Good Will Hunting we
all know this movie has the one that put
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck on the map
with their Oscar for Best Screenplay and
this movie is also filled with great
performances including one from Robin
Williams and yes I've heard your
requests and I will get to him soon a
flex biggest attributes in Good Will
Hunting are his authenticity his comedic
timing and his chemistry with Matt Damon
Will Hunting is a young man with an
extremely high IQ however he's never
seen the point in achieving his immense
potential or putting his mind to good
use he's challenged to do so by MIT
professor Gerald Lambeau and his friend
therapist Shawn Maguire when even his
best friend Chucky starts to question
why hunting works manual labor jobs
instead of using his brain to have a
better life will must decide what's best
for him as a crossroads presents itself
with Damon and Williams at the top of
their game in this it says a lot that
Affleck is not lost in the shuffle his
scenes range from really funny it's cool
it's cool cool
right school are you like me not $84,000
illumise a nerd detainer to effectively
dramatic you don't owe it to yourself
you owe it to me it's tomorrow I'm gonna
wake up and I'll be 50 and I'll still be
doing this shit that's alright that's
fine just sitting on a winning lottery
ticket that scene right there in the
Construction Yard might actually be the
best of the whole movie and it's because
of a flick you can see that he's not
holding back with his best friend but
he's very common matter-of-fact about
the situation there are a few emotional
layers at work here this also leads into
the ending when he realizes will is gone
great scene from Affleck with just the
reactions on his face it may not be one
of his biggest roles but Affleck turns
in one of his best performances in the
screen time that he had number four
George Reeves in Hollywood land he's the
current Batman but did you also know
that Ben Affleck played Superman well
not really I mean kinda based on the
true event of George Reeves as a parent
suicide Hollywood land follows the
investigation of his death while also
featuring flashbacks to the occurrences
before during and after his time as
Superman in the popular 1950s TV show
Adrien Brody is really the lead in this
movie and his storyline is okay but I
would have much preferred a full biopic
on George Reeves himself instead of the
flashbacks that we got here Affleck fits
the look of Reeves really well from the
physicality to the voice it all comes
together for him in this we really
should have had more of him we see a lot
of reluctance from Reeves as he's casted
to Superman George wanted to be taken
seriously as an actor and playing the
most famous superhero in the world back
in the 1950s really pigeon-holed him as
that character for his remaining years
however in public Reeves still made sure
that the kids who watched his show were
never disappointed when meeting him in
real life the following rejections and
crash of his career after the show
seemed to be a major contributing factor
to Reeves taking his own life
all those conflicting emotions are
portrayed great by Affleck he really
gets to use all his tricks in this
there's a great scene where Rees is
performing in a live Superman stage show
and a child pulls a real gun on him so
we can see the bullets bounce off
Superman
affleck talks him down and that scene is
filled with some really good suspense
like all the interesting reef stuff in
this though they cut it off early Kenan
why would you want to do something like
that so the bullet bounces off can i
well
if you did shoot me and the bullet
bounced off it might accidentally hit
someone else we don't want that to
happen do we we see reefs snap at his
girlfriend Toni Mannix when trying to
break up with her and that's a great
example of things hitting a breaking
point for the former Superman actor you
never helped me you could have talked to
Eddie you could have gotten me something
but you didn't because you're like me
where I was in a fucking red suit you
like that well that's not who I am you
understand god damn you but George
that's all you were good for 10 year
olds and shut-ins his girlfriend is
played by Diane Lane who's now
Superman's mom that's the rabbit hole
I'm not jumping into no there are
several potential scenarios shown about
what actually happened to Ruiz the final
and most likely one is the suicide that
is the official cause of death a flex
facial expression show a man who doesn't
think he has much to live for
the silent despair affleck puts forth
here is really impressive I don't hear
this one talked about as much and while
the movie isn't anything great Affleck
shines as a complicated man living a
complicated life number three
Batman / Bruce Wayne in Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice so I'll admit I
wasn't always on board with that flick I
was pretty upset when he was cast this
was taken the night it was announced I
was wrong Ben Affleck has proved to be a
really good Batman now I've said my
piece about this several times not the
worst thing ever but in general I was
not the biggest fan of BBS however with
Wonder Woman a close second I think Ben
Affleck's Batman is probably the best
part of this movie hold on hold on stop
right there what do you want Zack shut
up you walking popsicle stick nobody
cares about you let me take over know
what the people want me to do this this
isn't about no Zack now get out of here
fine batfleck has become quite the
phenomena I'm cool due to the
destruction of metropolis at the hands
of Zod and Superman many people of the
world including Bruce Wayne think of
Superman as a threat to humanity
Batman decide
the only way to protect the earth is to
destroy this threat meanwhile lex luthor
anaxes old plan to take down the Man of
Steel right away we get that this is an
older more grizzled Bruce Wayne one that
is supposed to invoke that of the older
Batman and the Dark Knight Returns
they get the tone of his character about
the same for the most part with a lot of
differences this take on the character
is a bit refreshing as we're seeing him
at a point in his life that's further
down the road from where he's been in
any other live-action version there's a
lot of pent up rage in this Batman that
Affleck played very well we get to see
his motivations for hating Superman we
see him in the middle of the madness
when metropolis is being destroyed and
the imagery along with his vengeful
stairs perfectly portray his anger
Batman is also scary in this there's an
unpredictability surrounding his
appearances that strike a chord with his
urban legend origins we also see some
great scenes when Alfred that ground
bruised and humanized him just enough
there's anger in some of his words he
has the power to wipe out the entire
human race and if we believe there's
even a 1% chance that he is our enemy we
have to take it as an absolute certainty
now I have to destroy him and
sentimentality in others this is a
powerful thing to think about I'm older
now than my father ever was this may be
the only thing I do matters yes there
were a lot of missteps Batman recklessly
killing being one of them but that's
another story for another time
overall Affleck has the potential to be
the best on-screen Batman I think that
in his solo movie we might see that
potential come to fruition time will
tell number two Bartleby in dogma this
movie was very controversial when it
came out and it's a pretty well-known
fact that director Kevin Smith received
death threats as a result of this being
released in theaters while I think it
may have went a little too far a couple
times I really like Dogma it's not
perfect but I think it has a lot of good
things to say Affleck and Damon as
Bartleby and Loki are the best parts of
the movie two fallen angels who have
been banned from heaven wander the earth
for years before finally finding a
loophole that will get them back in
paradise the problem is that it will
unravel existence a group that includes
Jay Silent Bob the 13th
and Bethany the last ion band together
to stop them Affleck and Damon play up
their light-hearted funny conversations
very well however as the movie
progresses Affleck becomes a standout
his arc is a very interesting one at
first he's the more level-headed of the
duo but later becomes the all-out
villain it's a slow turn that Affleck
really gets into there's a scene with
Bartleby and Bethany talking on a train
about their lost faith the writing here
seems very genuine and a flex delivery
is perfect it's a sad conversation that
shows off another layer to the Bartleby
character one day God just stopped
listening I kept talking but I got the
distinct impression that he wasn't
listening anymore I have to know she was
listening in the first place um yes I
don't things get really serious when
Loki questions Bartleby about the whole
plan
the monologue delivered by Affleck here
with Damon occasionally trying to snap
him out of it is the best scene in the
movie I asked you once to lay down the
sword because I felt sorry for them what
was a result our expulsion from paradise
where was this infinite fucking patience
then it's not right it's not fair he
plays a sympathetic villain that we can
understand the motivations for it's a
multi-layered performance that Affleck
nails by the way rest in peace Alan
Rickman Ben Affleck has done some great
work more than just five performances so
before we get to number one here are
some honorable mentions
[Music]
you
and the number one best Ben Affleck
performance is Nick Dunne in gone girl
this and the town are what made me take
Bend more seriously in recent years
while his performance in the town just
barely missed this list gone girl
provides us with a solid character that
is put through the ringer and comes out
the other side a changed man on the day
of her fifth wedding anniversary Amy
Dunne goes missing her husband Nick
quickly becomes the prime suspect as
police and media pressure close in on it
several revelations about the couple's
relationship and who they are as people
come to light during the investigations
questions lead to more questions as what
really happened Amy slowly gets
uncovered this was based on the 2012
book by Gillian Flynn the first time I
saw this movie it was difficult to see
Nick Dunne's motivations it was hard to
read him and that was by design Affleck
does a great job of planting doubt in
your head about his character as all
this uncertainty develops Affleck is
still likeable and charming you're
rooting for him even when you're not
sure of his innocence as the movie goes
along things get more and more intense
as we see all of Nick's secrets squeezed
out of him he slowly adapts and changes
as things get worse for him the
character surrounding him also forced a
change in his public demeanor which adds
another fascinating layer to this
performance Minkus
for in half an inch is the correct
answer hold your applause please mr.
make us you're wrong mom is he not right
I'll give this movie credit for
accurately displaying the insanity of
24-hour cable news coverage stories like
this often become a circus on those
types of shows and gone girl parodied
that type of national coverage perfectly
david fincher directed this compelling
tale and it has some really strong
rewatch ability a lot of that has to do
with how Affleck plays things when you
know how this story turns out his
performance is actually better upon a
second viewing if you're into salacious
disturbing mystery movies that have a
lot of uncomfortable truths in them you
probably like gone girl in my opinion it
contains Ben Affleck at his absolute
best thus far I want to hear what you
guys think what is your favorite Ben
Affleck movie and/or performance what do
you want me to cover next on the show
leave a comment and let me know follow
me on twitter at awesome underscore
walter and come back
next week when we count down the top
five worst Ben Affleck performances
until then we'll see you
[Music]
[Applause]
you